right good morning everybody welcome to
this latest meeting of the
um of the public covered 19 public
engagement board
can i uh i have apologies today from
laura hobbs dorothy evans
and helen grant uh but i welcome simone
anum who's standing in for dorothy i
welcome neil courtney standing in for
helen grant and i also welcome
uh julia uh burgess allen who is our new
public health consultant to her first
meeting
as well are there any other apologies
additional apologies have been received
from michelle hill
thank you very much are there any
declarations of interest
in any items on the agenda for this
meeting
that silence is golden fine thank you uh
minutes of the last meeting can i take
them as
read an enough record of that meeting
please
thank you uh then we're moving on to
item four
and i understand this morning that
eleanor wants to talk to us about
uh the national covered response plan uh
the easing of lockdown
changes in restrictions and the
implications for us
um in relation to that we've received
her report which again is
very thorough as usual so with no more
to do i'll hand over to eleanor thank
you
thanks thanks councillor freeman so um
what we thought we'd how was thought
we'd structure the meeting today is
around the road map to recovery
um and because most of the things that
we would want to talk about
are covered within that donna has put
together a presentation which we'll
we'll go through um but i want to just
start
with some some just general messaging i
suppose
for us as a as a borough um
what we're seeing at the moment in terms
of our cases is with we're seeing
the rate of decline stall so we were
going down although
our numbers were going down albeit more
slowly than in previous lockdowns
but we've really stopped seeing that
change and that reduction now
um and our rates are sort of stuck at
130 per hundred thousand
which is a concern and i think although
the good news is that we're starting to
see we're continuing to see a decline in
our older population
we have got quite a few cases in care
homes unfortunately still
um and i think although the vaccination
does seem to be stopping people becoming
seriously ill
we are still seeing those cases
happening in those care homes
um i think the particular thing i i want
to stress to everybody at the moment
is with the schools going back at the in
on the 8th of may
of march i think it's really good news
that schools are going back it's
absolutely essential that we get our
children back into schools
they've had a year of very disrupted
education and we know that that's just
not it's not working for children their
mental and physical health is suffering
as well as their education and it's
increasing inequalities
in the inequalities for our children so
we absolutely do need to do get children
back and i
am completely behind the decision for
schools to go back on the 8th of march
i think our schools are very well
prepared i think our schools have done
an amazing job throughout
and i mean i've said this before but i
really feel that the work that schools
and care homes
have done in trafford has been
absolutely exemplary
i cannot praise them enough so i do
think it's safe for children to go back
to school and i do think it's essential
for children to go back to school
however when children go back to school
there will be more social mixing
there'll be more mixing of the children
there'll be more mixing of adults both
in
terms of teaching workforce but also
parents gathering at school gates and so
on
so it's absolutely critical that we
understand
that our rates will increase when
children go back to school
and we need to do absolutely everything
we can between now and the 8th of march
to get our rates right down
and that means working from home if you
possibly can
keeping up with that social distancing
keeping up the limited
number of social contacts that you have
absolutely anything we can do to get our
rates down before schools go back
is going to stand us in really good
stead when the schools do go back
the other thing is that when schools go
when schools go back
we need to be making sure that we
continue to maintain that social
distance and continue to maintain the
limits of the number of contacts we have
and continue to work from home if we
possibly can
so really now is the time for any
business or anyone who's been thinking
oh well you know what i
you know i think i would rather be in
work or i would rather have my employees
in work
if they don't have to be in there if
that's not essential if there's any way
you can limit them being in your in your
workplace
please do that now because that is going
to be absolutely critical
in keeping us on track on this roadmap
and keeping the cases down
um i think uh the other thing that i
would be saying is about vaccination and
the role of vaccination within this
we're not going to be able to get to
herd immunity before schools go back but
what we can do is make sure that our
most vulnerable people are popular
are protected so again if you're over 70
oh sorry over 65 now if you have any
serious underlying health conditions
now is the time to get vaccinated make
sure that you get vaccinated and get
that protection
starting to work before those schools go
back and i don't want to over egg the
the drama about the schools going back
but i do think it's
it's a really good marker for us we've
got two weeks where if we put everything
we can into this
we'll end up with people in a much
better place and much better protected
we've given out so many vaccines now in
this country
we know they're safe and so please don't
pause the the risk
to if you if you're over 65 if you've
got an underlying health condition
the risk from covid remains very very
real and so please do take that very
safe vaccine
to protect yourself and the final thing
i wanted to say is
as part of a preamble is um
that our shield the numbers of people
who are
included in our clinically vulnerable
groups people will have heard that those
numbers are going up
we've had an initial tranche of
additional people come through
last week and the week before and we're
getting notification now of more people
in those groups
all of those people will be eligible for
vaccination and the gps have
have those names and addresses and will
be contacting people for vaccination
but again it's it's a plea to everyone
please do take that offer when it when
it's made to you
there is sufficient vaccine for all of
those groups and the
the vaccination doses supplies that are
going to the gps
are taking into account the additional
numbers of people who will
who will be offered the vaccine over the
next couple of weeks
um so it's it's um and the other thing
is that obviously all of those people
also become eligible for the shielding
offers and the support that's available
to them through the council which people
will talk about
more in a minute so i want to i'm going
to
um stop on that now donna are you able
to share your screen or shall i
try sharing mine for the
presentation
lovely so if we um if we just go
down so the next the um the next slide
so in within the um roadmap for
our cover 19 response and the recovery
it's divided into various sections
one on schools vaccinations four tests
in the roadmaps
behaviors test and trace variants of
concern
testing and then the economic and social
support so i'm going to just start
with the four tests that are being
applied so these the tests
of whether or not the covid
plan is working and the first one is
that is the vaccine deployment program
continuing and is it successful
um within that with trafford and and
others in the team we'll talk about it
more i think what we're really looking
at in trafford is making sure that we
get equitable uptake
and we make sure that all of our
population is covered um and that we get
to as close to 100
across the whole of the borough as we
can the second test
is to show that um that using the uh
collecting the evidence of the
effectiveness of the vaccine and so
that's about reducing hospitalizations
and deaths in people who are vaccinated
and that data we're hoping to start see
if the data from israel is very very
um promising and obviously we're
collecting our own data in the uk as
well so we'll be able to see more about
that but it probably won't be
um until the end of this month early
into next month that we
we're really able to say much with
confidence there
the third test is that the infection
risk rates don't
risk a surgeon in hospitalizations that
would again put the nhs under further
pressure
and i think for this this is why i think
this is the bit that locally
both in terms of the vaccine deployment
and the management of our local
infection rate
risk and making sure we get those down
those are the two things that absolutely
critical for us to manage locally and
understand what's happening
and where are our highest risk
populations and how do we support them
to be more covert secure and the final
test is that the assessment of the risks
isn't changed by new variants of concern
so these are the new very mutating
variants of the virus which are coming
through
and you would expect variation you would
expect mutation in any virus
but it's how well these will respond to
vaccination which is obviously one of
the critical issues for us
at the moment so we're
you know it's it's the same same
messages again and again about the safe
behaviors
the hand washing the face coverings and
helen will talk about the changes in the
school's guidance in a minute that's
maintaining the space maintaining that
social distance
stay outside if you possibly can when
you're meeting other people
try not to meet too many people at any
time every person you meet
is a potential risk and we know that a
third of people are asymptomatic
keep windows open and that's starting to
be slightly better advice now that the
weather is improving a little bit
we've got the test and trace app and we
would thoroughly recommend people use
that
if you have symptoms go for a test we've
got really good access to testing there
are no difficulties in getting access
to symptom testing if you have any
symptoms and if you do have symptoms
most importantly self-isolate if you're
positive
while you're waiting for a test result
or if you're told to self-isolate
because a member of your household or
somebody you work with or one of your
one of your friends that you've been in
contact with
has covered that's absolutely critical
that we get our self-isolation rates up
so the four steps step one is between
now
and the 29th of march and it has two
parts in it
um schools are opening on the 8th of
march and
you can start exercising and um i didn't
quite understand this one at first but
it the recreation outdoors
currently you're only allowed to meet
one other person um for
exercise you can now meet one other
person and for example sit in a park
with them
at appropriate social distance so that's
changed and then from the 29th you can
have two households up doors updoors
but households only indoors so we're
really making that distinction still
between the risks from indoor activity
and outdoor activity
and um sport coming back for children
from the 8th of march
organized activity uh outdoor sport uh
from the 29th of march
and um outdoor children's activities
reopening
um at the parents children's group
reopening from the 29th of march so just
in time
for those easter holidays and for travel
wise
it's still stay at home and no holidays
until the 29th of march
from the 29th is still no holidays and
it's minimized travel but some travels
allowed
so i think that's those are the first
two steps
and then the next ones are
the from the 12th of april and all of
these are no earlier than so this relies
on us actually abiding by the elements
within it and not
not trying to do things too quickly
because if we if we do
we'll end up all of it being delayed so
it really is important that we try and
make sure that we use use the benefits
of the restrictions
to bring help us bring those numbers
down and so from step two
it's the rule of six but back to the
rule of six two households outdoors
still households only indoors
um and retail reopening so big big
change there
travel is domestic overnight stays it
within the household but with your
household only
no international holidays still 20 to
the 12th
from the 12th of april provisionally and
from the 17th of may
we've got um a minimum of
maximum of 30 people outdoors the rule
of six
starts to play indoors so that's from
middle of may
all being well indoor hospitality
reopening
indoor entertainment activities are
really starting to get much more back to
normal
domestic overnight stays and potentially
some international travel
and some changes to events in particular
big events football matches and so on uh
concerts where you can start having
some of those events being held so i
think people will be very much looking
forward to that
and then from the no earlier than the
21st
of june it's effectively um
everything everything starts to be
possible i was on a call earlier today
and the person who was talking through
these steps
her birthday was the 21st of june so
we've um
we've all invited ourselves to her very
large birthday party
but um all of these dates are
provisional you know we don't
these
us to protect our most vulnerable people
to save lives
and we don't we have to be
understanding that these are provisional
dates that we hope
and aspire to reach and they're not a
guarantee and i think it really is
important that we understand
what part we can all play in making sure
that these dates actually
do become real dates and don't get
delayed further
um so that is what i wanted to say about
the
the steps and i'm now going to hand over
to helen to talk about schools
unless anyone has any questions on
anything that i've said
there's a question in the um in the chat
sir
eleanor from khan so
i'll i'll i'll leave all the schools
questions to helen
if that's okay that's fine thank you
over to helen
thank you thanks helena um i can't
actually see the chat on my screen but
if i go through
the key points around schools and then
we can pick up anything that's
outstanding afterwards if that's okay
so um just to say that as a public
health team we welcome the reopening of
schools it's such an important part of
children's health and well-being and
development
um that you know it's absolutely crucial
that we get children back to school and
they're back to school
safely um in terms of the work that
we've done previously with
all our education it's been really
positive and i would say that
our head teaches the capacity to manage
covid within our
education setting across trafford is is
really strong
and there's a really good understanding
of of the key kind of
actions that schools have to take so if
i start at the very early years so early
years there's no real change at the
moment
around any policy for early years uh
with the exception that lfd testing will
be available
to uh private providers from the end of
march so we're doing some work
around the earlier sector for that in
terms of primary schools again
no real change our teaching staff will
continue to lft test
and we can just say that it's been a
really good experience with the lft
testing across
all our educations the different
settings have really embraced
the um testing and we've identified um
a number of positives through that which
um and because they've been tested
at home on a sunday evening it's reduced
the disruption
um across the school setting so that's
been really good experience
for our secondaries this is where
there's more change obviously
so um from the 8th of march all
education will be going back
into the setting for our secondary
schools our children
and our staff will receive three tests
um going back into the setting the
reason why there's three tests not two
is around technique so that the young
people in particular get used to
self-swapping and become more confident
and there's
an element of supervision and we're
asking them
we're asking them to um the policy side
the guidance is that they get tested
and then they can return to the
classroom after their first negative
test
obviously you can appreciate the
logistics for some of our schools is
going to be significant
around this and we are working we have a
multi-agency
uh team with head teachers as part of
that team and looking at the key issues
and how we can work collectively to
support
some of our schools that may find it
difficult to to kind of work out the
logistics some of the bigger schools for
example
so they have to test them three times uh
with three to five days between each
test
um and then following the third test
children
and staff will then revert to testing at
home so children will be given
swab kits to test at home before coming
into school
um we recognize that there are some
challenges with this i have a teenage
daughter and
you know you do find things kind of
festering at the bottom of bags but
we're going to do lots of work with
schools
and with our talk shop service um to
really encourage
um the testing for students and really
look at how we can encourage
um the continuation of the testing as
well so that's something we're working
on at the moment
the other thing is that all students
will have to wear face coverings in the
classroom as well
um so we're doing some work around that
in terms of communicating
with our schools in terms of colleges
we've engaged with traffic college
and they are testing their students but
we still have some further work to do
with them but it's all very positive
um work that's happening um in terms of
further work that we're doing in the
next two weeks we're supporting schools
around the risk assessment identifying
where they need to just
ensure that they've reviewed their risk
assessments and that the risk
assessments alive
doing some prevention work as well so
making sure that we've got
communications out to parents
to students and staff around the need to
be
symptom aware the different types of
testing so just to make sure
people are clear that lfd testing is
only if you don't have symptoms
pcrs if you have symptoms and you need
to self-isolate
and then um encouraging those people who
are eligible for the vaccine to get
their vaccine
but also to continue with the strong
messages around social distancing
and reduce mixing
the other message is so the other way
that we engage with our schools is we
have fortnightly
q a sessions with our head teachers
which are really really well attended
on average we have about 70 people
logging on and it's a very active
network
lots of questions and a lot of learning
jointly from our team and from the head
teachers
themselves about what is happening in
school so it's really strong
and but what we're also mindful of is
it's not just about return to school
isn't just purely about covered risk
we need to be aware that these young
people have been
you know away from the school education
setting for the last three months
so we're very mindful around recovery so
thinking about
through all of our school nurses around
mental health physical activity and the
wider issues that
will challenge some of our children
young people and their return to school
so that's all the work currently that's
going on in education um i can't
actually see the questions on my screen
i don't know
if that's answered um khan's question
will all teaching and support stuff in
school will have had their vaccination
in time
this calls to open eleanor can i hand
that question to you
you can and the answer is no they won't
but
some some will because at the moment the
vaccination program
is aimed at making sure that we reduce
the risk of death and hospitalization
and that's why it's based on
ages and on clinical vulnerability the
reason for a number of healthcare
workers and social care workers being
included in the
first tranche is because of the need to
keep the hospital systems running and
obviously particularly for older people
making sure that we have adequate social
care
and our care home sector is working
effectively
is a really critical part of the the
whole hospital
and health care system so at the moment
there has no the um vaccinate the joint
committee
on vaccinations the national um but
independent
body that advises on vaccination
programs has
advised that we should vaccinate
according to age
and risk fact risk factors clinical
vulnerability
and that no occupational groups outside
the health and social care
field should be prioritized at this
point
obviously a lot of teachers have a lot
of concerns about that
we have provided vaccination in traffic
there has been vaccination provided for
people
who work with the most clinically
vulnerable children
but by and large and obviously teachers
who
as the anybody with any underlying
health conditions themselves will also
have been vaccinated
but the majority of teachers won't have
been vaccinated before children go back
having said that we have been opera you
know schools have been open throughout
the pandemic
admittedly to smaller numbers of
children and have been managing
really well with that and we're openly
in the autumn when we had
probably at points in the autumn when we
had higher rates of infection than we do
now
so um we share and
understand teachers concerns but we
continue to feel that
the the schools have done a lot to make
sure that those
um workplaces are safe and we thoroughly
um you know we recommend to teach us
that they continue to follow all of the
safe behaviors guidance
and we know as well that all while we
have had outbreaks in schools we have
had bubbles closed
in many many cases those have been from
uh
children or adults bringing infections
into schools
rather than spread within the schools um
so we um
we it's it's that difficult message we
we have to get children back into school
and we we are really grateful to our
teaching workforce for what
what they're doing um but we do feel
that the the measures
um do provide as much protection as we
can
at the moment to that to that workforce
thank you eleanor uh before i invite
questions
can we have the presentation today
circulated to all members to the peb
and chair i've just um put the document
um
that has all the graphics in but we can
send you the presentation as well but
that does have the graphics in case
colleagues want to share them with other
people as well chair
thank you donna i'm just wondering
[Music]
whether uh it would be useful eleanor as
well to
eventually have a look at it for
circulation to all elected members
to keep as part of an update absolutely
and
i mean i'm very happy to we can
circulate it will also circulate with it
the full
government document because that gives
all the detail and it's very it's
very easy to read documents it's a good
document
and obviously i'm always happy to do um
if we want another all member briefing
at any time the public health team will
always be happy to do that
and i think that might be uh in maybe
two weeks time very very useful actually
and to coincide with the schools going
back i think we could try and arrange
something for
all members that'd be very good uh i've
got a question from councillor welton
first thank you
hi uh thank you uh councillor freeman um
just wondering uh
if the uh focus on the uh on the north
of the borough and that at the
the area that was bordering on the um
the area of manchester with the new with
the
uh new variant i'm just wondering if
there's been any
you know if there's been any statistical
success
um from that program uh and presumably
it's only just an
update presumably it's ongoing so the
the operation eagle in
manchester is ongoing um and they have
found a number of cases
of covert but i think they're still
waiting to see whether that
um with what the pc what the genomic
sequencing
tells them because that takes a little
while um
we have been um and i think it's nigel
on the call
yeah nigel's on the call so nigel will
be able to talk more under our community
engagement item about the work we've
been doing in the north but we've been
really focusing at the moment on
particularly on increasing
vaccination uptake in the north and
listening to our population in the north
regarding particularly any concerns they
have about vaccination but also making
sure that we understand
where there are difficulties for them in
self-isolation or in accessing testing
so i think that you know that the
population in the north of the borough
is is one that we are we continue to
have particular concerns about because
that population because of other under
well underlying health conditions
more overcrowded housing more likely to
be doing face-to-face work
are always going to be at high risk of
spread of disease
what i would say is we continue to see
cases across the whole of trafford
we have nowhere in trafford that is
covered free
um and our numbers you know one of the
good things of numbers coming down is
you get more
um that's a good thing but you can get
more volatility so a single household
starts making
more of a difference but um we are
definitely still seeing
uh cases across the whole of the borough
this is not something
that is limited to the north by any
means
absolutely you know we very very much
spread across the whole bar
all of our wards have above 50 per
hundred thousand cases
which is the who level for concern
i don't know whether we um a couple of
other people with hands up or whether we
want to talk about
vaccinations um and whether um
if donna talks about the testing program
and helen about the contact tracing and
then nigel a bit about communicate the
comms and then we take the questions i'm
hoping that somebody
will come in from the ccg on vaccination
but otherwise i'll talk about
vaccination
um but if i hand over to donner on the
testing um
as people know as well the army um have
been supporting that
and we've got some changes there so if i
hand over to donna
thank you elena um i think uh
what we've tried to um do is just
summarize anything new in the
uh roadmap um as you'll be aware the
testing program
either pcr or natural flow has been now
cascaded to some
key groups um so workplace testing for
um businesses that over have over 50
um are starting to be rolled out as you
know we have a local
asymptomatic testing site at trafford
town hall
which eleanor has said has been very
efficiently
um run by our colleagues from the
military they will be withdrawing
on at the end of this week and we have
now staff in place who would double
running it with the um
army said that we'll be able to take
that over from
um from next week we've seen about five
and a half thousand people tested
so um that that's great news but i think
as the different models of testing
um start to emerge and we will start to
understand whether we need a further
site or whether we're going to have a
different models of delivery
um our care home staff our nhs staff our
teaching staff
now have their own kits delivered direct
to their own settings
as do um settings in supported living
and those
um high risk extra care settings um
i think uh one of the things that came
up chair in the
um the new document in spring was
something called a
community collect model and i presume
that will be on the basis of having a
number of sites
um throughout trafford where people who
aren't able to go to central sites
or who can't access it through their own
workplace will be able to go and collect
their own testing
sites uh testing kits so i think we
haven't
confirmed it yet but we have obviously
loads of community sites we've got the
hubs
we've got um the libraries we've got um
the gp health centers we've got
pharmacies
so we'll just be drafting together a
series of um
opportunities where we can have that
community collect model
and as soon as we have further
information from the government about
the numbers
we'll then be able to present that to
make sure we've got equitable
access for all our residents thank you
thank you donna um so shall we move on
to
is rebecca with us for much vaccination
rebecca isn't there's another meeting
with the ccg that clashes unfortunately
with this one but on in terms of
vaccination the general news is
extremely good for trafford we're doing
really well with
with our uptake um we have had a
we had a lower uptake in the north but
that is now starting to be remedied
which is
and we've been working very closely with
alia and others with invoice bme
and with carton um the caribbean
african caribbean network as well to try
and understand what reasons there may be
for people
having concerns about vaccination and to
try and allay people's fears
so we are starting to see that changing
and we've also very positively
um there have been additional
vaccination clinics set up in the north
which are more accessible to people
so closer to where most the people in
that in that population live
in the so in limelight and that see more
growth so those clinics will
continue to be run and we will be making
sure that we use
um announcements such as including um by
the
mosques through friday prayers about
trying to make sure that we get really
good promotion of the vaccination
clinics
and that we get that good uptake in
those clinics um the
trafford i think is doing best out of
greater manchester i think when we've
delivered more than 55 000 vaccinations
now um and at our total population as
you know is 237 000
but children wouldn't be included in the
vaccination program at this at this time
it's not licensed for children so it's
general good news about vaccination but
this continued
um as shown nationally
a strong link between a correlation
between lower uptake and more deprived
areas
and those areas aren't of the areas
where people are more likely to be
seriously ill
because of all the underlying health
conditions are more common in people in
deprived populations
so it really is absolutely imperative
that we get the
vaccination rates up in those
populations and that's something that
the ccg is taking very very seriously
and i'm sure alia will be able to talk
about that and nigel
um on those both those issues
at that point can we just i know council
accordion was waiting with a question on
vaccinations mike do you want to ask a
question now
uh yeah thanks chair in a sense
i it worries me that the the knee-jerk
reaction that is
is down to deprivation and um
ethnic minority and all the other
if you like stereotypes
the figures i saw for the north in the
dashboard yesterday
were so at variance with the rest of the
borough
that it has to be a much bigger issue
than simply
um difficult communities that that was
um i mean
the north was barely hitting 70 percent
well it was actually below
70 where everybody everywhere else was
all scattered around the 90 89
90 bigger that's significant that isn't
covered by deprivation
that that is one third less in the north
um that is a huge
difference um and i think
and i think we need to go a little bit
deeper than that and
and and think about the actual health
infrastructure there as well
there are lots of issues you've you've
talked about
um making sure that we've got
vaccination facilities in old trafford
which is good but
burswood is a different part of old
trafford and it's not necessarily
covered
by yours and no ghost hill is a
ghost hill proper is a different part of
old trafford to certain extent around
the stadium
there's no facilities there there's very
poor gp
infrastructure uh in terms of the
building the gps themselves may be very
good
but in terms of the infrastructure we've
lost one
the other one's basically a converted
sharp it's
it's not good in that area and i think
it's too easy for the message to go out
that it's simply because of different
language and things like that there are
some really
underlying issues in terms of providing
health
in the north and and it's showing up now
um so i i'm a little bit concerned that
we immediately can
and and the i'm not do i'm not i don't
want to downplay the baame
and we need to carry on all that there
are difficulties and suspicions
but once we've dealt with that there's
still an issue in the north and it would
worry me
if we didn't deal with that i almost
feel that it's too easy to say
it's b.a.m.e and it's deprivation
actually this the figures are so
different to the rest of the borough
that there's something more going on
there you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right the i think the
the initial difficulty that the ccg had
was that they had to provide they had to
find
very fast back to four vaccination sites
across
um trafford and they had to find them in
find them in places that had car parking
there were a whole load of conditions
that needed to be put into place
and the vaccine supply chain was a push
model rather than a pull model
so rather than being thinking about how
do you get you know how many vaccines
does each area need
eat different areas the different the
five different primary care networks
were just sent fairly randomly supplies
for vaccines sometimes at short notice
the site chosen for the north was at
dalamir which has
many advantages as the site but one of
its strong disadvantages
is that it is not properly located
within the heart of the old trafford
area and therefore there was significant
issue of access for
that north trafford population so i i
would i absolutely do not think that
um it's reasonable to blame people for
not being vaccinated and i absolutely
think it's about how health service
you know i i would i don't i would never
describe as
a community as difficult or hard to
reach um
it is about how people engage with them
and
how much trust we've been able to get
and how much we you know
we it's about earning trust isn't it we
we
treat some communities badly and then
when we want to we suddenly want them to
engage with us on our terms so i i
completely agree with you
that it is about making sure that we've
got accessible services
and that we also deal with the hesitancy
vaccination is a huge exercise in trust
as well and if you have a population
that for whatever reason
hasn't had good experiences or doesn't
have trust in
some of the state systems for all sorts
of reasons
then you know it's a big ask to say to
people
trust us on this one so i think i think
there is
a lot that we need to be doing in
particular in the north of the borough
about making sure that our populations
really feel part of trafford part of
part of our main offer able to be
included
and wanting to be included in in that
the offers that we make and the way that
we deliver services
so from my point of view i think this
covert work has really
all the way through covid we're just
seeing again and again the impact of
lack of trust between different
communities
and lack of services lack of appropriate
service delivery
in different parts of the borough and
this is a real wake-up call for us
i'm really pleased that the ccg when
they when you know when they started
looking at the
the data and started seeing that big gap
in in the north
have acted and have put on additional
clinics in more convenient locations
and they are absolutely determined to
make sure that that continues and my
understanding
is that as the az vaccine becomes more
widely available
because that's much easier to store and
so on that it will be much more based
around gp practice
and therefore should be easier for
everybody to access
um from a from a surgery within walking
distance to
to them um the other thing is that i
think we're certainly seeing now more
people wanting the vaccination because
they've seen this it's been rolled out
elsewhere
and that it hasn't been leading to
harmful effects so we're we're getting
some people who maybe a month ago were
thinking i'm not sure about
it and now being asked again and i've
been thinking you know what
actually i think it is safe so that is
really really positive
so part of the message is just making
sure that we continue to make the offer
and make the offer in a way and in from
venues that people can actually reach on
foot
wherever possible so i i think
but i do think it's this whole thing is
teaching us
a lot about how we deliver services and
how we design services in trafford
and how we do better in the future and i
think if you know if
if something good comes out of covid i
really hope it will be
how we think about our populations
differently
yes cancer courtney yet are we
are we sure it's all down to refusal and
not
um just not seeing the invitation
i'm sure that some of it will be down to
missed um not seeing the invitations and
that again
if um nigel and alia will be able to
talk a lot about the work we're doing in
in particularly in the north of the
borough
but anywhere where we start seeing
particular groups and we are doing an
equalities impact assessment
on on the covid programme and
vaccination program to make sure that
we're really identifying
if there are any other any groups so for
example are men less likely to take up
the vaccination than women
is it by geography what are the what are
the issues behind
any um any gap in intake up so that we
can then
try and put plans in place to address
them
thank you i've got a further question on
vaccinations from
councillor new gross and then eve
mannerings wants to come in as well so
i'll start with council news rush
thank you chancellor freeman um so
mine's all about equip equitability of
delivery
if i could say the word equitable
delivery um
i know that we're getting national uh
vaccine
deliveries in a in a sort of a random
way from
the nhs that we are outside our control
and that traffic is smoothing that to
make sure that it's equitable
i do have an issue though the ward i
represent
three gp surgeries are not part of the
program
they are the only three gp surges in
trafford and we have
stepped up with the uh lark hill center
um
however the problem is that the alark
hill center
is outside of our ability to smooth
and i would like to know how we're going
to get around this we
for just for instance i have a surgery
half a mile away from me advertising
uh 50 plus the last of their 50 plus
they're just finishing cohort
nine cohort nine
and and that is not standard across
trafford so
i i how are we going to to fix that for
timpali
so i think the the message there is that
we are very much trying to work with the
national system we
across the ccg is strongly supporting
the jcvi
um program and therefore the
prioritization program
that's used um by that which means that
at the moment we're actually only on
cohort five
um i know they have been in discussions
with the um
with the practices who are extending
their offer
as the ccg and the practices are hoping
that we will be able to move more to a
pool model rather than a push model
which means that people will be
only able to call down the vaccinations
as they are
as they are required rather than going
out of scope
um i mean we can
i think we may need to return to this
when we've got the ccg on the call
because
it's um it's difficult to meet for me to
speak for them but i do know the ccg is
taking
the jcvi um prioritization program very
seriously
but the supplies of the vaccine do not
come via the ccg they go direct to other
organizations and i think
for me as well i think this stresses for
me the need for locality ownership
of the vaccination program and making
sure that we have
an ability to manage that for the
borough to make sure that the vaccines
go where they need to go
in the right order there have been
suggestions with some of the later
stages of the program that there will be
increased use of mass vaccination
centers such as the yeti had
i have serious concerns about that
because i believe that will increase
inequality
because it means that it will be very
difficult for people without a car
so from a public health perspective and
certainly across the greater manchester
directors
public health we are putting submissions
back into the center to say that we want
to see
this program delivered in the main by
gps or by pharmacies in local areas
to minimize travel and minimize
difficulty for for our residents in
accessing vaccination
because we believe otherwise we will see
an increase in inequalities
so that that's certainly my my view on
this is that we need to be
looking at this from the borough level
and making sure that we get the vaccine
to where it needs to be as quickly as we
can and as fairly as we can
thank you and uh can i just say uh and
reassure council knew gosh that
the um ccg are taking the national
program very very seriously it was
confirmed to us
at an executive briefing yesterday by
martin pritchard
and the sort of thing that council
newcast is talking about where we are
finding people
going out of step is actually a
potential cause
for quite a lot of community resentment
in certain areas
um and and i know as somebody who's
still waiting
and into my 60s i'm quite relaxed about
it
but i do know of people that aren't
getting the vaccination
that you're thinking well why then uh
and not me and and that's just an actual
natural reaction
so i i but i do i can reassure cancer
new cross that
uh the the ccg are taking the national
role out you know and sticking to it and
trying their very very best
um and i'm gonna bring eve many
mannerings in please
eve hi there yeah thanks very much chair
um
so for those of you who don't know me
i'm the chief exec of the local medical
committee
so the spokesperson for general practice
on the call i guess
and i just wanted to pick up a couple of
points
by the two gentlemen who have just
raised two separate issues from the
north's perspective i just wanted to
provide some insight into the struggles
that general practice is having in the
area
they have contacted me directly to ask
how we can support along with public
health colleagues
getting the right messages out to the
population
we contacted kate green mp and she
kindly
recorded a video for her constituents
that was circulated out the unfortunate
thing is
when i went on to check for the
resources around
um information on covid that were very
accessible
in in alternative languages i went on to
nhs england and phe and there was
nothing
available there was just zero um in
alternative languages
thankfully there are another a number of
organizations which
have got things in place doctors around
the world being one of them
so the gps um are very much aware of
that and there's been a lot within
greater manchester as well i'm part of
the association of greater manchester
lmcs and there's been a lot of videos
tailored
in a lot of different languages to reach
people that have been
circulated so i just wanted to
provide some assurance that gps are
reaching out to communities
i think um might you raise a very
important point about
perhaps premises and i think north does
have some issues around estates
in particular which is a much bigger
piece
um and an issue that does need to be
discussed
at greater depths because i think there
is a disparaging
in the premises available in the north
for the population
uh just to touch on the simply
uh query as well um i i am aware because
i have been liaising with the three
gp practices um who didn't sign up
it isn't a mandatory um offer that that
they have to do it
they made the assessment that there was
a risk to their patient population
for things other than covered in doing
so and again
premises was a concern of that they are
in contact with the pharmacy
and supporting um with the data that
they
need to do the invite and my
understanding is one of the main blocks
is the lack of vaccinations available
i do understand that site does have good
capacity
in line with everybody else it's just
guessing the vaccines into
the right place so i will take that
feedback away um and speak to
who i need to speak to and get an
absolute update on the situation
and i'll report back okay thank you
thank you very much steve uh george
devlin
uh you want to come in uh yeah again
um just to introduce myself for the
purpose of this meeting i'm currently
the
interim chair of the ccg so it's just to
say that
the conversation that we've heard
particularly from
uh councillor the two councillors who
spoke we will take that information back
to the ccg
uh apologies that rebecca couldn't make
the meeting but i think
eleanor has has answered most of the
questions that were raised
i think one of the things that i would
say is that what covert has done is
really shine a light on inequality
and it's showing a light on things that
we knew were there before
and as a ccg one of the things that
we're committed to doing is to try to
resolve
some of those underlying issues that
counselor cordon has highlighted
in terms of the health service provision
and i think some of the areas that
eve has just picked up on is indicating
the commitment
and i think i'll just go back to the
initial
conversation around the vaccine it has
been a
good success in trafford and i think the
work that people have done
and put in to make it a success from the
gp community from the ccg
and from a community perspective has
been quite remarkable
and that's what we're looking to build
on as we're going forward
thank you george thanks for that input
um can we therefore move on to
uh to nigel smith please to give us an
update on community engagement
thank you
thank you councillor freeman uh yeah so
um
in terms of uh the work of the community
engagement team as eleanor
had mentioned at the start a lot of this
work has focused in the north of the
borough and in
in particular tackling issues around uh
related to vaccine hesitancy
um this is links into the latest
government road map
which obviously highlights the need for
high vaccine take up
to be crucial in enabling the
restrictions to be lifted
and the government report talks about
the fact that although
nationwide there is excellent uptake of
the vaccine there are early signs of
lower up
vaccine uptake in lower income and some
ethnic
minority groups and um
these groups are those that have also
been disproportionately affected and
impacted by the pandemic so that is
highlighted within the government's
uh road map so
in terms of the activity that we've been
on take undertaking over the last couple
of weeks just wanted to highlight
some of the work that we've been
carrying out
um the vaccine hesitancy work is
coordinated through weekly meetings that
we have there's a covi
covid vaccine operational group that's
led by the ccg that we're part of
and also an internal council meeting to
review activity um
as mentioned by eleanor before we are
one example of the work we're doing is
to feed messaging into the friday
prayers at the mosques every week
for example to promote the vaccine take
up and also that messaging is also
distributed
through the mosques through whatsapp
messaging groups
for example this week as well there's a
local gp from the bain community who
will be delivering a talk at one of the
mosques
at this week's friday prayers we're
also working with voice of bme who are
an old trafford based community group
and they'll be helping to tackle uh
vaccine hesitancy and are working with
the north primary care practices and
contacting
patients via via the phone
we have taken part in webinars and q a
sessions to gather community feedback
and concerns which has
included the voice of bme uh the
caribbean african health network
khan and the old trafford community
network
meeting and we're planning further
webinars and q and a's over the coming
weeks
and linked to this as well we arranged
for eleanor to deliver a training
session for the voice of bme card and
other representatives of that
the old traffic community network
we supported uh community messaging
around
the uh those the pop-up uh
vaccination clinics in old trafford at
seymour grove and limelight
to help increase that vaccine take off
and obviously with those
with future clinics we'll be following
that up and doing the same
uh another example of the activity we've
been undertaking
is we've been working with a local high
school in in
stratford to assist them with developing
community messages
and uh myth busting among their peers
and families and they've
developed a um an initiative called
virus gone viral which that they're
gonna be promoting through
various social media sites
we have also been working with the sail
life center vaccination hub
and making use of the various digital
screens and other signage they've got
there
so this works going to involve looking
over
the uh the schedule of what demographics
are in on what dave is and providing
targeted messaging in line with our
schedule
supplying supportive messaging around
the importance of the second dose
and we're going to be assisting with
production of materials
and continuing to get feedback from the
center volunteers
at the site in terms of what
alana mentioned before around the new
additions to the clinically extremely
vulnerable list
um they are being deviced to shield and
will have
rapid access to the vaccinations via the
by the pcn
so again it looks like um
the majority of the new cev people will
be
um in the north of trafford so
in response to this we're currently
developing an action plan to help
alleviate any concerns and again to
promote vaccine uptake so we're looking
at
firstly to do some door knocking to
speak to individual households we're
hoping to do that next week
we're going to be developing some
leaflets and materials in different
languages
setting up a booking help desk and
potentially also using
an ivan to deliver messages at key
football locations to highlight
the vaccination clinics and also to
highlight the booking help that we're
going to have available
the team have been continuing to support
the volunteer program
uh for the testing sites and vaccination
centers
working with colleagues that thrive in
the ccg for example
the vaccination clinic at partington and
i know there's been some good
local and national press coverage on two
people in north of the borough who were
initially hesitant but then decided to
take the vaccine and that was at the
delamere bellamy clinic
and uh just a couple of final things to
mention the community champions work
plan
is being taken forward so we're
developing a website where
champions will be able to sign up where
we can give them the latest information
about kobe 19
which they can then share with their
community and we are looking to get in
some support for our champions which
will involve regular
information and check-in sessions so
we're looking to help that website
launch within the next couple of weeks
uh just to mention on the business
webinar we talked about this at the last
peb meeting so this took place on the
11th of february so the webinar was
was really excellent and those that
attended it was really well received so
we're looking to share
that webinar with other businesses and
post snippets from the webinar to share
on social media
and also to look at have further
webinars with specific
groups and our comms and economic growth
teams are also continuing to promote
the support which is available to
businesses through the various uh social
media and
other kind of networking routes that we
have
so that's the update for me council
freeman thank you
nigel i've got uh khan wishing to make a
comment
uh khan thank you chair uh first of all
thanks nigel for giving a comprehensive
report on what is being done uh with the
different communities and
everywhere else really especially in the
north of the borough
i just want to make two short comments
one
is to do with the messages on friday
prayers
one of the issues is that first of all
because of the covet restrictions the
the speeches have got to be very very
short so in other words there's only the
the essential speech which is done in
arabic
and really it doesn't give much time for
another message to go out
and also people who actually come to
pray on fridays they just come to pray
most of them don't want to listen
anything so but
but we should not actually just stop
doing that secondly i think which is
more important
is that we have a challenge with these
conspiracy peddlers who spread out these
conspiracies
and we should be able to on social media
somehow issue very instant rebuttals
uh i think that is where our big problem
is and the big challenge
how can we very quickly issue a rebuttal
especially on social media which is not
easy to control
so those are the two issues which we as
a community we are actually dealing with
it
all the time thank you very much for
your efforts
and i can tell you that people actually
believe what you're trying to do
is a good thing and we are seeing many
many more people
coming in to take up their vaccinations
thanks
thank you and thanks for the comments
and and
and the praise for the work that is
going on
um i know it's ellie is with us on this
and
um in relation to to to people that are
against
lockdown or or are spreading this
well ellie would you like to comment
please on on what we're doing at present
please thank you
yeah and i mean obviously we've had a
conversation around it um and there are
a number of people in the borough who
obviously um not only hold views which
are contrary to public health advice but
are
quite intent on sharing those views with
other people and
the the nice thing to see um on our
social media posts is that often other
residents will engage with
um these people to talk about their
theories and to you know
share what is clearly um accurate
information with them
and we are taking steps to remove um
comments or um articles that people
share that we
could be harmful that we think
contribute to
um vaccine hesitancy whilst also not
denying people the right to have their
say so it's finding a balance between
what is
potentially harmful um and and
leaving things that actually um generate
healthy
conversations between people so we're
just trying to strike that balance at
the moment
thank you ellie um are there any
questions at all for
uh on this side from anybody at all it
might call uh is yours a legacy handmark
accordingly
yeah sorry that's okay can i be cheeky
and take advantage of it
it wasn't yes go on
in in terms of communicating i'm
interested in what um
khan was saying really and in terms of
how we communicate
particularly with um difficulties
in terms of the mask and what have you
um
people are still going out um
messages on the the there are very few
of the old-fashioned
posters about suggesting um
i don't know whether we're getting the
message i worry about it all being
social media frankly
i worry that i i think a lot of the
issues in the north
are to do with absence of electronic
communications rather than
um more communication we
even um contacting people to call for
their vaccination by text is
problematic and that seems to be the
main mode at the moment
um it's a text that you get
um so i'm wondering about whether we
should be
improving older fashioned communication
posters things like this in sharp
windows and
what have you um in different languages
and reaching different cultures but
um i certainly know that
a lot of there is take-up there is
take-up amongst business people and
things like that
local people that could be if they could
be persuaded to be role models and put
their name forward i've had the
vaccination
you know and and this sort of thing i i
worry that
we're missing too many messages that
we're channeling it almost sort of at
national level sort of well-known people
and
and not in our communities and i think
some of the community
um i'm more than willing to be
those good referees
good communicators um it doesn't all
have to be the mosque
the mosque is useful but it can be
everyday
sorts of things i see eleanor's but
knows
ellen wants to jump in go on eleanor i
mean i
i was going to suggest that alia as well
talks about this because
um we are working especially one of the
things has been through the rh world
board we're getting community champions
and we're really hoping that those
people will do some of this work with us
but also um
a lot that we do know that webinars and
donna has done a brilliant webinar
um with dr goga and snippets of that are
being used in social media but we do
know that actually for a lot of people
it's having that individual conversation
that makes the difference
so throughout we've been doing helen's
been leading some great work with
schools where we have q and a's with
head teachers and that has been really
helpful for us to understand what the
messages that and the difficulties that
schools are having
um we've done donna's been leading work
as well with care homes and with care
home
staff so we are really trying to make
sure that we have opportunities to have
conversations where people can ask
direct questions because we know those
direct questions make more of a
difference
and then the work that um alia has done
in the past and is now picking up
um on uh the actual phone calls to
people who
are perhaps delaying their vaccination
and the work that nigel's team is doing
is very much about that getting out in
communities rather than relying on
people
seeing things through social media but
i'm sure alia will be able to talk
more intelligently than me on on the
work that we're doing
on this and just to reassure eve we do
have lots of materials in different
languages
and i'm a particular fan of audio files
as well so
um ellie perhaps could get in touch with
with you afterwards eve but if i can ask
alia to talk a bit about the work we're
trying to do that more face-to-face work
that would be great
yes thank you very much thank you very
much
for giving me this opportunity to speak
um
a little bit about what voices of bme is
doing uh first of all i think
it is it has been such a valuable
remarks has been given by mike i really
appreciate
uh highlighting some of the things and
nigel thank you very much for
providing us a comprehensive sort of a
report what we talked about
so the webinar which we delivered i
really
uh i'm grateful to elena and donna for
supporting into that
because it was it provided so much
insight
of what the vaccine is for myself and
because
uh for the whole team and all for
everyone who was attending because it is
more or less like when we talk to the
community
if we are in an informed position we can
cascade the
information in a better way so this was
an opportunity for people to
come up with some of the questions which
uh i emailed
then dr dr goga and don and then
those questions were answered on the web
and asked a recording
will be very soon on our social media as
we promised
we're just trying to snip it because of
the data protection so that
people's identity could be concealed so
that'll be on
soon uh in addition to that the work
which we
uh which mike again said that we have to
may perhaps
look at some of the ways to communicate
in a different way
i 100 agree with you mike we have to go
back maybe onto the drawing board and
consider some of the things which can be
done differently
and amongst that is a one-to-one contact
i i'm i'm a big advocate about that
because it when it comes to health and
when it comes to risk
we can talk uh to a person more clearly
on one to one basis instead of having a
group conversation
group conversation is equally good but
if a person can open up
and clearly talk to another person who's
more knowledgeable on the other side
is always a plus plus and this has been
a successful
model when it came to about the
screening so
we are thinking of rolling out in the
same way for the
for the vaccine and i'm very positive
with the support of public health and
ccg we would be able to make this
difference in the north by having a
winter conversation over the phone
to the people and um if any concerns
we that that will be raised by the
people on the other end
we will come back to you so this is
these are the two
main aspects we are going forward with
uh but
i am very much positive uh to support
you guys
uh in any way if wasabi can be i know
khan is regularly attends this committee
and i usually
come in as and when needed but i thought
that will be a good opportunity to
listen what
are the going way forward is and to um
some of the things which we are doing
into the community so
uh thank you very much for providing me
this opportunity today
no alia thank you very much because
clearly there's some very very important
and very detailed work going on and
we're very grateful for that
i've got uh councillor at to wish you to
come in
yeah yeah thanks chair uh it's just
really to say
um i think uh my colleague council
accordingly has made some
excellent points um this morning
and i i think it has you know the
pandemic has shown a light really
um in the lack of some you know health
care support really uh within
the north of the borough um and i i
think he also makes a really good point
about
the um you know how we actually
um you know communicate
with the public i i just remember um
you know the active travel uh
consultation
and and all the signs that went up in
um flixton ernst and dave eu
to to actually tell people there was a
meeting on a certain date
and hundreds and hundreds of people
turned up
um and you know it it's things like that
there was all these yellow big yellow
signs in the area
about the meeting and you couldn't miss
it you know you just could not miss it
if you went out of your door you would
see
one of these signs and it worked
in terms of that particular issue i'm
not saying it would work
uh with the vaccine uh but
unless we try things differently
we will never know and uh and i really
do
believe that mike has shown a light on
on
a number of key issues uh this morning
and
uh you know and i hope that we will
react to
to to to some of those so thanks chad
thank you councillor acton and and i'm
sure we'll take it we've heard what's
been said they'll be taken away and
looked at
and and i'm sure ellie's been taking
notes this morning
we move on the um of time um can we move
on then to
um neil neil courtney who's going to
update us on
escalations from the community
enforcement group
neil thank you very much councillor
freeman um as far as
um reports of breaches of the
regulations um
the past week uh we've seen a slight
decrease
uh in the number of reports up to the
21st of february
um so a 15 total decrease in reports
what we are starting to see now um
interestingly is that a lot of those
reports also include
other elements of either anti-social
behavior or crime
so where previously the report might
have been about gatherings in somebody's
living room or garden
and that was the extent of the report
that now including things like drug use
and noise
uh and other things and then the covert
breach being almost a
a secondary issue to the to the behavior
being complained of
the geographical spread of those reports
it seems that
most of them are from the north and the
south so approximately a third from the
north a third from the south
and then the remaining third split
roughly equally between west and central
the enforcement group does continue to
meet every monday
um to identify risks around this um and
a further tasking and operational
meeting now takes place
on a tuesday between gmp and various
council teams environmental health
licensing and so
forth um what we are seeing uh and i
think is something to watch for
um next week is that following major
government announcements we do tend to
see
an increase in reports of breaches i
think it puts it back into in the
forefront of people's minds and so
those calls do do increase after a major
you know after
after the prime minister's spoken um so
it'll be interested to see next week if
after the announcement on monday we see
a further increase in calls
and next week's monday meeting will also
include
um what the the impact on enforcement
will be
um based on the government's
announcement of the roadmap
um there is a general sort of sense
across the the teams that are in that
group
um that there's perhaps uh
among some some some people um a lower
perception of risk
um based on the really good news about
the success of the vaccination program
so there is perhaps a concern that that
is is lowering the perception of risk
um and the necessity to to abide by
um abide by the rules among among people
um
but that's conscious of time that's
that's my update um
if anybody has any questions i'd be
happy to try and answer them
uh thank you neil uh very succinct that
i i do know that
um our uh um
environmental health continue to work
extremely hard with yourselves
in in in going and advising businesses
and
i note that we did have a business
promise a gym
fined last week um i have to
say that that is only the second
business that's been fined
in since the outbreak of this pandemic
so the evidence
is is that we are out there actually
supporting business which is the right
approach to take
um and um has anyone got any questions
at all
on this session uh chair
yes but that's recording just the other
aspect of um
what what's going on out there
we we have a a youth
some i i'd say between 15 and
almost 20 50 the 15 to 22s
um very disillusioned
young people out there really
really sort of fed up with everything
real life schools are going back on the
8th which is good
but there is a lot of the the a lot of
the crime seems to be linked
to this whether it be motorcycle crime
whether it be
you know setting fire to the park
everything from
the other aspects of this are a really
sort of disillusioned youth i actually
worry about the 8th of march i think
i think a lot of kids will be really
really pleased to go
back but there will be a small
proportion that thinks
their education's gone that actually
it'll be very negative and i worry about
this on the crime side
i realize that we're mainly focusing on
businesses and raves and things like
that and almost partying
but actually out from the sort of
walk in the street sort of aspect the
the the real
problems and more in terms of almost a
disillusioned youth that um
and i think i i i i wonder what the how
the police
are prepared for the sort of 8th of
march and how things
go from there on well
can i just say i i don't think it's just
a police approach it's also a
a council community uh uh
approach and i do know that we have
actually put money and neil
confirmed this into our youth outreach
work specifically to work around parks
mike at the moment
with youth that are causing that are
potentially at risk of
causing annoyance or anti-social
behaviour neil do you want to just
come back in yeah there's a there's a
number of different sort of initiatives
and i think it's really important that
this work continues
um through the eighth of march and
beyond um so we we do have
um through the serious violence fund
work money that was put into
um detached youth work going out and
engaging with these young people
where where they can be found um that
that
started last year that's been done again
this
this financial year to kind of increase
the capacity of
our of our detached youth for a team to
be able to go out and engage engage with
young people
not just because of kobe my my normal
role is dealing with
with youth violence and and um and that
kind of that kind of offending
um so i think it's really important that
that work continues there's an awful lot
of engagement with schools
um that's still gone on throughout the
lockdown and will continue
um going forward um to identify perhaps
young people who are
struggling a little bit more um than
than their peers um both with with
behavior and then the situations at home
that go on
um and work that's been done there um
and then there's
there's outreach work being done through
through the voluntary sector as well
uh with young people and foundation 92
um
have spoken um a number of times around
the the council recently about some work
that they're doing
um in in the central area um and and
then what we're also seeing is
is gmp and their communication across
all four localities
has has really increased around the
problem with
with young people so each um each month
now there is a locality tasking meeting
where this is discussed and information
is shared so i think
i think it's really important as
councillor freeman says that it's not
just the gmp problem
you know lots of different departments
within the council are looking at this
uh and are heavily involved in this and
then you know the voluntary sector as
well
thank you neil um has any other
questions
i don't see any um
i think we've had a very very productive
meeting this morning um is there any
other business at all from anywhere else
thank you i don't see any any hands
raised
can i thank you all for your attendance
system
this morning please and i take it we
meet again in a fortnight nights time
um and i look forward to the
presentation this morning being
circulated
thank you very much for your time this
morning thank you everybody
bye-bye thank you thanks very much
everyone
sorry